starship will be able to carry 1 000
passengers from sydney to dubai
in just 40 minutes the largest
mainstream passenger airplane today
the airbus a380 can carry up to 853
passengers
that same route will take you 13 hours
and 35 minutes to complete
in other words in the same time that it
takes one airbus a380 to travel from
sydney to dubai
starship can transport over 20 airbus
a380s worth of passengers
between the two locations which is over
000 passengers so here's how much these
tickets will cost
and how starship will make long distance
aviation
obsolete
starting off mainstream space travel is
basically inevitable at this point
people switched from walking to chariots
and from chariots to cars and from cars
to planes
so it only makes sense that the average
person switches from planes to
spaceships for long distance travel
as a result the real question is the
time frame for making this a reality
the primary concern when looking at
rocket-powered mass transit
isn't actually the technology itself we
have seen massive rockets since the
1960s with the saturn v
starship will be the largest rocket ever
built
but not by that much of course the full
reusability aspect does make the project
significantly more difficult but this is
not the main bottle cap
rather the main bottle cap to
commercializing space flight
is reducing cost winning over government
approval
and most importantly earning public
trust
starting with the cost of space flight
if we take a look at the cost of reusing
falcon 9 today
the advertised cost is about 50 to 60
million dollars per launch
but that's how much it costs nasa and
satellite launchers
if they want to use falcon 9 provided by
spacex as a result
it's actually much cheaper than that for
spacex themselves to launch the falcon
9.
in an interview with aviation week in
may of 2020
elon musk revealed that the marginal
cost of relaunching a falcon 9 rocket
was only about 15 million dollars and
it is important to note that about 10
million of this goes towards the
construction
of the new upper stage as the upper
stage of the falcon 9
is not reusable aside from this 5
million dollars goes towards
refurbishing
and reusing the payload fairings and
surprisingly
only 250 000 actually goes towards
refurbishing the booster
fortunately for starship it only has two
parts and both of them
are fully reusable moreover though the
current animations show both parts of
the rocket being used for point-to-point
travel
elon musk has since updated us that it
is expected that only the top part of
the rocket will be used
for point-to-point travel so that wipes
out the 10 million
recurring upper stage construction cost
as well as the fairing refurbishment
cost
of 5 million this is because the upper
stage of starship
is likely to boast refurbishment costs
closer to the refurbishment cost of the
current falcon 9 boosters
of 250 000 as opposed to the 5 million
refurbishment cost of the fairings
considering this
the marginal cost of launching
point-to-point starship rockets
may be as little as just 250 thousand
dollars
but of course there are many other costs
than just a marginal cost
for starters we have fuel expenses
fortunately though
musk has revealed that fuel costs are
only about 0.3 percent
of the final cost of launching a rocket
so for a 60 million
falcon 9 launch field costs are expected
to be about 200 000
if we throw in another 50k for good
measure we have fuel costs of about 250
on top of this if we throw in another
250 000
for any miscellaneous expenses such as
ground crew and
anything else that may be involved in
launching a rocket we have a pre-launch
cost
of just about five hundred thousand
dollars to seven hundred fifty thousand
dollars
now i know what you're thinking that's
unbelievably low
and that's exactly what i'm thinking too
but this
is in line with musk's proposed pricing
elon musk claims that starship will be
able to send people to mars for just
2 million per launch and mars missions
will require the bottom part of the
rocket
or the super heavy booster on top of
this did i mention that the rocket will
have to travel over 1600 times
the circumference of the earth so if he
is able to do that for two million
dollars per launch
500 thousand dollars to 750 000 for
point-to-point travel within the earth
wouldn't be that surprising this of
course excludes the cost of research and
development
and the rocket itself however these
won't be
nearly as expensive as the falcon 9
because spacex will be able to spread
out their r d
and vehicle costs over many more flights
than with the falcon 9.
the expected cost of mass producing
starships is only about 5 million
even if it ends up being 10 million it's
just a drop in the bucket compared to r
d costs
which are expected to cost anywhere
between 2 billion
and 10 billion calling r d 20 billion
it still wouldn't be that hard to recoup
these costs with the full fleet of
starships
here's the thing if we had one million
dollars per launch to recoup r d
costs as well as vehicle construction
costs we would have a pre-launch cost
of one and a half to two million dollars
if each starship were to just fly
once per day and we had 20 starships
that would be 7
300 flights per year pulling in 7.3
billion dollars in gross profit
at that rate they could easily pay off r
d within just a few years
after launching point-to-point travel
even if we add another one million
dollars in actual profit for spacex
point-to-point launches should cost no
more than three million dollars per
launch
with 500 000 to 750 000 going towards
the actual day-to-day operation cost of
starship
one million dollars going towards
recouping r d and vehicle costs
and 1 million being net profit with the
1 000 customers per flight
this comes out to a per ticket price of
2 500 to 3
000 so at first it will be quite a bit
more expensive than
long distance flight tickets but this
will come down with time
within 10 years of launching spacex will
have had plenty of time to recoup all of
their initial r d costs
at this point they can drastically
reduce rd costs within the launch price
by 70 or 80 percent as r
d will simply consist of improving as
opposed to developing
from scratch at the same time spacex can
take advantage of economies of scale
to reduce the net profit margin instead
of profiting one million dollars per
launch from a few dozen starships
they can profit 250 000 per launch from
hundreds of starships
accounting for these cost reductions
starship launches will
only cost about 1 to one point two five
million dollars per launch
which comes out to a per ticket cost of
just one thousand
to one thousand two hundred fifty
dollars this would make starship ticket
prices
quite comparable to the respective
long-haul flight ticket prices
which are generally several hundred
dollars but that's not it
within a longer time frame of 20 to 30
years after launching
spacex will likely be able to further
take advantage of economies of scale
and further reduce profit margins and r
d costs
in an effort to reach more customers
aside from this
it is also likely that within this time
frame the refurbishment cost per launch
as well as the fuel efficiency will both
greatly improve
thus allowing spacex to offer
point-to-point tickets for relatively
the same price
as long-haul flight tickets at 750 to
all of this sounds great but when can we
actually expect all of this to see a
light of day
well the first hurdle would of course be
winning over government approval
as of just five days ago elon musk
remains confident
that spacex will be able to send unquote
car commissions to mars
by 2024 with crude missions following in
the late 2020s
this is elon musk's time though so we'll
double it just to be safe
and say that we'll put people on mars
using starship by 2040.
twenty years also gives them plenty of
time to prove the reliability
and safety of starship to governments
and us with that being said
they should be able to soft launch
point-to-point travel in the 2040s
during this time frame most people will
still not feel safe
riding in a spaceship and will mostly
the enthusiasts
as well as some business people who
trust the technology
using it for anywhere between two
thousand and three thousand dollars per
seat
after this pioneering phase we'll likely
see early adopters flow into the system
in the 2050s these guys have seen
starships travel safely for a few
decades at this point
and they're willing to spend one
thousand to one thousand two hundred
fifty dollars for the ticket
in return for the massive time savings
this
is personally when i would start
considering using the system
following this in the 2060s we'll see
prices drop to 750
to 1 000 per seat and this will be
pretty close to the final price
of starship tickets at this point
starship tickets
will be reasonably affordable to the
average individual
living in western countries and this is
likely when we will see the irish person
take their first trip on a rocket
finally
between 2070 and 2090 we'll see starship
tickets
drop to the lowest they'll likely go at
600 to 800
that is of course before accounting for
inflation anyways
at this point the average person will
start preferring starship for long
distance travel
over airplanes considering their similar
ticket price and proven safety record
with that being said this is when we'll
see the vast majority of long-distance
airline options
being phased out airplanes will however
still likely serve domestic routes
as a rocket ship simply wouldn't make
sense for such use cases
and all of this leads me to the
conclusion that starship
will likely crush long distance aviation
within the second half of the century
do you guys think the transition to
starship will be slower or faster than
what i outlined
and how low do you predict starship
prices can fall
comment that down below also if you guys
are excited to potentially travel
in a rocket ship within your lifetimes
then drop a like
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one